I'd like to share with you a piano  metaphor to have you have a better  understanding of how ASL works so  Envision a piano  ASL is broken down to many different  grammatical parameters  if you assign a different parameter to  each finger as you play the piano  such as facial expression  body movement  speed  handshaped  and so on as you play the piano  English is a linear language as if one  key is being pressed at a time however  ASL is more like a chord all 10 fingers  need to come down simultaneously to  express a clear concept or ID in ASL  if just one of those keys were to change  the chord it would create a completely  different meaning